the jurgen experience yeah
there's two things that i wanted to talk
to you about before we got in here
besides the election
in no particular order aliens and george
soros
[Laughter]
hey how do you know they're not
connected they might be connected
but both of those things i find um
particularly fascinating i never knew
that about you the george soros thing
just keeps coming up
over and over and over again where
people that i know that are very
intelligent and some that are very
connected
say that he's funding a lot of these
antifa
rallies and protests and and chaos
and that they're funding the political
campaigns of people
that are opposed to putting people in
jail and that are promoting
air quote social justice and all of
these
reforms and all of these political
movements that seem to be deteriorating
the the trust in law enforcement and
that there's
some sort of organized campaign by him
to do something to destroy the fact of
the fabric of our democracy yeah sort of
the one world government run by george
soros that's the
batman villain storyline yeah i
i think uh the truth is is less uh
exciting or interesting uh i think he's
he's he puts a lot of money into a
handful of organizations and that money
gets uh
funneled out for various purposes
campaigns
uh supporting um organizations there's
no doubt i think that that
he his worldview is is somewhat
different than
than mine um but i don't think that
soros is uh you know running some uh
campaign to take down america i think
that's
why do you think people are so attracted
to that idea is because of batman movies
yeah you know everybody loves a big
villain he's an evil looking guy i mean
i think again hey i don't mean that
wrong but you know
he can't help no one's fast no offense
there you look like you could be in star
wars yeah i mean
he's yeah he's he's got that look about
him
you can see him in a black robe yeah you
know
your director off and you know hey
he could do something about those bags
under his eyes frankly he doesn't want
it he's got billions of dollars yeah i
know
what gets a person's rocks off when they
have that much money and they're
you know they're still trying to make
more money and they're basically
i mean how old is he 80. how old is
george soros
he's got to be in his 80s right he's
he's in the home stretch
90. he's not 90 9-0 he's in the home
stretch kids
does it say how much money he's giving
away of his he's worth 8.6 billion i
don't know about
giving away he's not giving anything
having donated more than 32 billion to
the open society foundations according
to wikipedia wow he's worth eight he's
donated 32.
that's a man committed yeah and see
that's part of that that's crazy the
connection to open society i think is
probably what helps to fuel it but
i mean you got a guy that what does that
mean he's an oil easy
uh what do you call it uh he's an easy
um it's an easy
foil an easy target to be um in
i mean it's like the koch brothers
there's no difference right it's just
one side blames the koch brothers for
right you know uh trying to take over
america and and
one side blames soros so what is that
organization jamie
open society oh
open to the open society foundation
support individuals and organizations
across the globe fighting for freedom of
expression
accountable government and societies
that promote justice and equality well
that sounds good
it does sound good it's confusing yeah
so all these people that think he's evil
truth and justice i mean but if i was
going to be evil i would hide behind
something like that
it sounds like a person and you can
imagine some of that money getting
eventually funneled making its way to
organizations i'm not saying it's
happening but an organization like
antifa or whatever
you know the the theory being oh no
we're trying to promote you know if you
if you wrap yourself in the cloak of
promoting
equality and justice most people aren't
going to push back because they don't
look like a dick right right you can get
away with a lot of [ __ ] yeah so you
don't you don't
you know but i anybody who's like
this is um one of my things if you're
gonna give money to an organization
you know do a little investigating first
find out how much of it goes into
people's pockets
and and actually where the money goes
and what it's used for
sometimes it's easier than not and if
it's difficult to find that information
now give your money somewhere else right
because it's not
there should be transparency around any
any operation that's asking you for a
donation or for your money but soros
when he funnels that money and makes its
way through it's like a pachinko
machine right it's kind of it's just
kicking all over the place right
so it's it's no surprise but uh so do
you think it's just that
it's an easy target for someone who's
looking for
like one person who's the puppet master
who's pulling all the strings right
everybody loves it's a simplistic way of
looking at things
yeah and i'm not saying that source
isn't funding groups it wouldn't piss
people off i guess but
you know there's more to it there's more
to it than that but
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love